it is March 26 2023 and you are watching
the code report epic games just
previewed some new tech coming to Unreal
Engine 5.2 and it's unreal because it
makes 3D Graphics look too real they
demoed this rivian truck driving through
the jungle and the amount of realism is
crazy like rocks and dirt flying off the
wheels and plants reacting to the motion
of the vehicle what's crazy though is
this truck contains 71 million polygons
and each tire has a million of its own
tiny little meshes which to form the
terrain around it all rendered in real
time like this is not a Pixar movie
where all the graphics are pre-rendered
offline in advance it all renders in
real time based on user input made
possible by unreal's micro polygon Tech
called nanite which was released exactly
one year ago that's old news but today
they announced a new material framework
called substrate and to demo it they
changed the paint job on the truck to
Opel which has extremely complex
colorful Reflections but on top of that
you have multiple layers like a clear
coat and dust on the vehicle as well and
the reflection changes based on how
these layers interact with each other
this allows you to create different
materials with different shading models
and layer them together which could be
really useful when splattering blood and
guts everywhere in a violent video game
that's pretty cool but they also just
introduced a brand new suite of
experimental procedural generation tools
what they did next is drop in a
procedural assembly into the environment
and this is kind of like a prefab
developed by an artist however it
interacts with the surrounding
environment as the assembly is dragged
around the environment adapts to it and
does so in a deterministic way that can
be configured by the developer in
addition this tool can be used to create
large worlds very quickly you can create
an infinite number of unique Landscapes
by simply tweaking some settings and
that means in the near future almost
anybody could build a massive open world
game without the need to plop down every
single asset it doesn't replace
hand-drawn artwork but it does allow you
to scale it much more efficiently unreal
also announced updates to its fortnite
editor which basically allows anybody to
create their own custom fortnite world
it's a very Savvy business move by epic
games because it's the perfect stepping
stone into the Unreal Engine game
development ecosystem it's kind of like
Roblox on steroids in addition they
announced fab.com a new unified
Marketplace for 3 3D assets where
creators will keep 88 of the revenue of
anything sold there it'll be really fun
when they have procedural assets there
that you can buy to generate a massive
world with minimal effort and finally
that brings us to yet another crazy
announcement The Meta human animator
this tool allows you to record your face
on your phone then reproduce it as a
high fidelity animation for a character
in your game if you're a good actor that
means you can create terrifyingly
realistic facial animations that rival
Hollywood like this demo of Hellboy 2
using Unreal 5.2 but all this makes me
wonder if this Tech is on a collision
course with artificial intelligence
imagine a world where anybody could just
describe their own fantasy world and
have it procedurally generated on the
fly in 2023 we already have hyper
realistic text to image generators text
to video is getting better every day and
The Logical next step is text to video
game I'd be surprised if epic games
wasn't already working on generative AI
tooling the technology might still be a
few more weeks away but I for one can't
wait to build my own epic metaverse and
start living in my own perfect unreal
world this has been the code report
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one
[Music]